the pandemic forced many businesses to
make tough decisions
that includes changing operations for
one owner who wanted to help unemployed
entertainers find work
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with more on the effort
kristen sasha this business is in the
historic commercial center on sahara
near maryland
it opened in june after adapting to the
covet 19 situation and
noticing a need in the community
[Music]
rita lim gets ready for her show
i'm doing a tribute to the carpenters
she takes the stage inside the vegas
room
an intimate supper club giving lim and
other local performers a place to work
entertainer right now is suffering a lot
because not everybody is employed
but this spot aims to change that it's a
platform of
hope for so many talented people in this
city
to come and do what they do best come on
in
tom michelle is president of the venue
he says last year forced him to change
the business model
and recognize a need vegas room actually
was going to be a catering
business until covet hit there was so
much despair when it came to the
entertainment community and
so many talented people in this city
that we started doing live streams from
our house called live from the vegas
room
following the governor easing pandemic
restrictions the vegas room gave
performers a chance to work again
in person after finding success
the owners are expanding a few doors
down the nevada room is about 7 000
square feet
about a little less than half of it's
going to be dedicated to a piano bar
bistro
crews continue remodeling the space from
a former mexican restaurant
when done michelle says the three venues
plan to center around
one idea local entertainment with a
business that was built
for locals that allows lim and others to
share their talents
i'm grateful for all of nisin and
support
michelle expects the piano bistro to
open soon and the nevada room in
early summer live in the newsroom i'm
kristen drummond 8 news now